today we're going to talk about how to
regrow your hair so whether you are
losing hair or your hair is becoming
thinner or you have alopecia this video
is for you I wish I could say there was
a magic pill you could just take to
regrow your hair but there's a a couple
aspects about this that uh you need to
understand especially as it relates to
your foods and your diet so what is hair
hair is protein right it's a type of
collagen and so do we just eat more
protein that's the question well what is
protein protein is bunch of amino acids
the building blocks of proteins and out
of all the amino acids uh there's one
that's very very important it's called
lysine lysine can have a huge effect
over whether you grow hair or not it
seems to be one of the most important
amino acids but it can affect the hair
in many different ways the first being
making sure your hair is very very
strong and elastic okay so how do you
get lysine what foods are high in lysine
well not plant proteins or grain protein
proteins both of those are very poor
sources of Lysine one of the best
sources is you guessed it red meat it's
also an eggs and this is really relevant
now because so many people are telling
you not to consume red meat it's bad for
you it's bad for the environment well
I'll tell you right now grass-fed
grassfish beef is very healthy for your
body as well as for the environment so
we definitely need the quality of
protein right something that has high
amounts of Lysine but also the quantity
right how much protein you consuming
enough protein if you're doing a high
quality protein you won't need as much
if you're doing a lowquality protein as
in plant-based proteins you're going to
need a lot more but with that comes a
lot of anti-nutrients specifically
things like Fates which can block other
factors that we're going to talk about
so on average I would say if you
consumed let's say six to eight ounces
of protein twice a day I'm talking about
like red meat uh or it could be eggs it
could be other types of protein uh that
would be sufficient another thing that's
interesting about lysine is it helps you
absorb iron and a lot of people with
hair loss are low in iron iron is
essential for making hemoglobin it's in
your blood to supply the oxygen you need
in your scalp one of the big symptoms of
anemia is hair loss so providing your
scalp with enough iron so the hair
follicules can have the nutrition is
very very important lysine help you
absorb it as well it's the same food
that's high in lysine it's also high in
iron red meat animal protein eggs but
when we think of iron you want to think
of about everything red like a red meat
versus white meat like chicken has a
little less it has some but it's very
very high in red meat as well as organ
Meats now I haven't left this topic of
Lysine because there's a couple things
so you need to know about it um when you
go through stress the demand the need
for lysing goes way up so if you're
going through a lot of stress and you're
losing your hair that could just mean
you need to increase more protein and
another factor for the absorption of
Lysine is if you have any type of
inflammation in your gut you have
malabsorption and that could be the
reason why you're not absorbing these
amino acids so here this person is
eating a lot of grains thinking they're
good creates inflammation the gut
because of the gluten and other factors
and then that person can't absorb amino
acids and minerals anymore and so now
they lose their hair so your gut is very
very important as well and this could
explain why a lot of people going on the
carnivore diet uh get their hair back
now I personally am not on the carnivore
diet I like my vegetables and I also
like my animal proteins as well but for
those people that have gut inflammation
okay I think they should go on the
carnivore for at least a few months
because certain properties in that meat
will heal the gut so there is a really
interesting connection between your
digestive system and your hair think of
the digestive system as like the roots
in the soil so the plant above the
surface is what you can see and you can
see if it's healthy or not well in our
bodies the hair is the plant right and
the roots are in the gut and this brings
up another topic uh gut disbiosis or
your friendly bacteria okay your gut
microbes actually make amino acids okay
they make certain proteins and if
there's a disruption of the Flora
inside you're G to have an alteration in
the chora on the surface of your scalp
not to mention dandruff and other types
of skin disorders so some people when
they start getting on a probiotic from
being on an antibiotic for a period of
Time start noticing that their hair
starts coming back and their hair is
thicker interesting so we can't just
look at the body in isolation we have to
look at the whole picture and many times
if you have an overgrowth or some type
of fungal overgrowth or whatever on the
surface of your
skin the way that you fix it is through
the internal gut you you have to start
taking more probotics or prootic foods
like sauerkraut kimchi kefir things like
that let's talk about another thing it's
called DHT this is a very powerful form
of testosterone that has been known to
um cause a burnout of the hair
follicules or even the thinning of the
hair so there's all sorts of medications
out there that inhibit this
DHT and help you grow your hair but of
course they come with side effects so
what are some natural um DHT
Inhibitors well a big one is zinc okay
which happens to be in the red meat
again too so consuming more red meat
will actually kill three birds with one
stone but zinc is very very important in
regrowing your hair for other reasons
too but it does inhibit this DHT problem
but you also have lysine lysine itself
can inhibit DHT so getting enough
protein again will help you from many
different areas you can also do pumpkin
seed oil you can do green tea extract
you can do nettle root these are all
natural Inhibitors of this DHT and if we
can reduce that we can then eliminate
that barrier if that's one of the causes
of your hair loss now just as a side
note lysine is the precursor for another
molec
called carnitine and I've talked about
carnitine in other videos being very
very high in red meat but cartine
shuttles the fats into the mitochondria
for fat burning or oxidation and this is
why a vegan might be low in carnitine
because they're low in lysine and this
is another reason why people seem to get
a lot of energy when they consume red
meat now another interesting thing that
happens when you're low on lysine is
that you might have a t tendency to have
high triglycerides in your blood for
this very reason there's low carnitine
to shuttle the triglycerides into the
mitochondria for energy production
lysine also helps decrease stress
because it can help lower cortisol it
can help lower your heart rate in
recovery it can help lower the risk of
herpes infections which is to keep this
virus in remission in one study
apparently lysine can help lower
glycation in the kidneys of diabetic
rats and improving insulin resistance so
this lysine molecule is quite widespread
all right this leads us to the next
topic chronic stress you could
definitely lose your hair with chronic
stress a lot of people go through too
much stress and they end up with
alopecia autoimmune diseases and just
general hair loss why is this because
cortisol is a catabolic hormone it
breaks things down and stress activates
cortisol our bodies were not designed to
to have this sustained high level of
cortisol over a long period of time so
how can we lower cortisol lower your
stress and so what you have to know
about that is that stress can deplete
you of zinc and or increase the demand
for zinc and zinc itself can help reduce
stress and just as a side note um you
need to really understand what can
deplete you of zinc sugar alcohol and
stress other things are really important
reducing stress and also helping your
hair at the same time vitamin B1 other B
vitamins too like B5 B12 which can help
someone if they have anemia so you can
actually have anemia from a lack of iron
mb12 and other things too where are you
going to get those B vitamins
nutritional yeast is a good source but
another way that a lot of people are
helping their guts especially if they
have a leaky gut or an inflamed gut to
fix that they go in the carnivore for a
period of time so these are just some
things that I think you should be aware
of and you should try as the most
important actions to get back your hair
now because of the censoring and the
suppressing of the algorithms on YouTube
it's becoming more difficult to find my
content and there's a lot of content
that I cannot put on YouTube
unfortunately so to make sure you have
full access of all my information go to
drberg.com And subscribe to my
newsletter by clicking the link Down
Below in the description I will see you
on the other side now if you haven't
seen my other very popular video on
growing hairback you should check it out
I put it up right
here